take education to me a lot of it is
asinine when they pull people and
they're like hey what do you want to
learn in school people be like
gardening
you know are how to have a friendship or
how to take rejection or how to you know
work on a car engine or how to pay bills
right and and have like a banking
account you know all the stuff that they
people say they want you don't ever
spend you don't learn [__] about that
you spend my son is 18 like some of the
stuff like his math class is like give
me a break like he's not going to be a
mathematician and he's in like this
it's so hard and it's so pointless and
yeah and you get something out of math
like you it it exercises your brain
right it's like Advanced Sudoku right
um which is good for brain oh yeah but
it's not practical at all and like he
took this history class and his entire
history class like European history was
just about who won what battle you know
in 1707 the French beat the Polish in
1842 the English Beat the Dutch and yeah
and the Dutch beat the gays and you're
like what is this is this hey yeah
where's this going yeah like who's
writing this yeah yeah I agree man but
who cares about that like who who cares
who won the Battle of shish kebab and
you know in 1684 you know yeah 100 I'd
much rather learn how to how to you know
if I was 17 to have a checking account
or how to grow a cabbage yeah oh it'd be
sick dude you saw some freaking hot
chick with a balanced checkbook and two
heads of lettuce you know what I'm
saying buddy
but dude yeah I agree there should be
client like I always thought there
should be classes on like
um like we had spelling every week right
three kids did the best 16 kids did
medium four kids could not spell ever
yeah and it was the same for the whole
like after four weeks let's just say
we get we know what's gonna happen yeah
let's move on like I think let the four
kids yes just Duke It Out Among
themselves yeah I was always in the
medium yeah I was a good speller you
were a good speller yeah did you ever
make it to some kind of finals I made it
almost but I missed on inconvenience
right that's inconvenient yeah I wrote
that line on the in the office
um uh I lost the spelling bee I
misspelled the word failure
and uh I actually wrote that line I felt
kind of proud of that here's a class you
should have right rain
eye contact
what a great class the first week it's
all eye contact how you doing Betty you
know what do you what do you what about
the second week
then you move up you do nodding
so why don't you just say like
interpersonal communication yeah
one yeah you put that you're scaring off
a lot of folks that's okay let them be
scared okay kids need it people need it
right now you know you look on college
campuses and some of the most popular
classes like the most popular class at
USC is on friendship
like how to have friendship yeah well
it's yeah I mean because look what we do
you yeah I think you do eye contact
nodding you if you you do well in
nodding you get to you get to move into
the handshakers Union right and then
you're there you're doing real
handshakes in real time with people
right right but you're learning yeah how
to communicate how to take rejection
like you said that would be great oh
damn you suck oh man all right bro but
I'm still good at this right but we
teach it's like we go straight from like
dinosaurs to sex ed it's like you
believe in Tyrannosaurus Rex let's [__]
you know
like that's crazy bro yeah we there's so
much as right none of it is based on no
one has ever [__] a dinosaur
oh I I believe no because they never
overlapped humans and dinosaurs never
overlapped it's like million a year
after the last dinosaur died before
humans there's no pictures of humans and
dinosaurs at the same time
well there's no there's no pictures
before 1880
there's paintings but yeah there's no
there's no wall carving woolly mammoths
yeah it could be that someone [__] a
woolly mammoth oh yeah in the plasticine
brunettes they called them back then
yeah you know art they're so woolly yeah
oh especially on a whole night yeah oh
sure oh oh sure I would braid that tail
sleep in that vagina it's like a
rucksack
oh I bet if they had a newborn baby if
they're riding on a woolly mammoth they
just plop that right in there yeah yeah
why not
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one